Netflix is always adding top-notch
movies to its library but it's also
constantly taking options away here are
the movies you have to watch before they
leave Netflix in November 2000 19 until
November 1st you can dine in Hell
alongside Gerard Butler's king leonidas
by watching the 2006 action film 300
directed by Zack Snyder 300 is based on
Frank Miller's comic book series of the
same name which offers a fictionalized
retelling of the real-life Battle of
Thermopylae that occurred in 480 BC
during the greco-persian Wars Butler top
lines the film is Leonidas leader of the
Grecian city-state Sparta who takes 300
Spartans in a battle against the King of
Prussia Xerxes and his 300 thousand
soldiers this is a flick filled with
violence action and bloodshed and is
sure to please anyone keen on watching
Gerard Butler swing around a sword and
kick his enemy into a pit
[Music]
the original 1980 sports comedy film
Caddyshack Starz Chevy Chase's ty Webb a
golfer at Busch wood Country Club the
elites establishment which Ty's father
co-founded gets a rude awakening when
the loudmouth new-money golfer al played
by Rodney Dangerfield takes the green
bush wood is also dealing with a
seemingly never-ending war between an
evil gopher bent on destroying the golf
course and Bush woods ground keeper Carl
Spackler whose intent on exterminating
the rodent like its predecessor
Caddyshack 2 was also available to
stream on Netflix until November 1st
Clint Eastwood's 2008 drama Gran Torino
is a movie you certainly won't want to
miss before it leaves Netflix while you
might know Eastwood from his time in
westerns Gran Torino sees the actor
tackling modern drama the venerated
actor directs produces and stars in Gran
Torino a film about a widowed Korean War
vet who forms a unique relationship with
his neighbor Tao critics have held Gran
Torino and high esteem so if you've yet
to see it for yourself you have until
November 1st to learn why until November
1st subscribers can stream Groundhog Day
which follows Phil Connors as he relives
February 2nd 1992 over and over again as
he does he slowly learns to respect
others to open up his heart and even
save another person from death easily
one of Bill Murray's best films you
might not get another chance to see the
film on Netflix again soon it Suites its
inventive it spawned a whole new meaning
for the term Groundhog Day and it's on
Netflix for only a few more days I'm
sorry what was that again I'm of God
your God I'm a god the scream franchise
and the scary movie series go together
like peanut butter and jelly it's hard
to have one without the other
Netflix subscribers can sit down for a
double feature like no other by watching
wes craven's iconic slasher flick scream
which centers around high school student
Sidney Prescott's and the masked
murderer who's stalking her and her
friends then you can immediately follow
it up with scary movie 2 a spoof on
supernatural horror movies that covers
everything from The Exorcist to The
Amityville Horror
both flicks will stick around Netflix
until November 1st after you've
thoroughly satisfied yourself with
Halloween candy retire to your couch for
a 6-hour binging marathon until November
1st Netflix subscribers can stream The
Lord of the Rings the two towers and the
Lord of the Rings The Return of the King
a vinyl to install
of the Lord of the Rings trilogy
following the trials and tribulations of
the fellowship as they reunite with
Gandalf orchestrated an attack on
Isengard head to Mount Doom in Mordor
destroy the One Ring and fight against
the vicious Sauron it's high fantasy at
its finest then you've got a few days
left to enjoy it on Netflix featuring
one of the biggest twists in movie
history The Sixth Sense centers on a
young boy named Cole Shearer who can see
dead people
Cole's troubled by his paranormal
abilities which leads child psychologist
dr. Malcolm Crowe to find the truth
behind the boy's visions in the end they
both get more than they bargained for
and viewers get one unforgettable plot
twist the sixth sense is available to
stream on Netflix until November 1st
have an extra three hours to spare and
want to spend it doing something
meaningful stream Richard link Lauder's
sprawling deeply intimate Academy
award-nominated opus boyhood the film
follows a boy named Mason Evans jr. as
he comes of age in Texas alongside his
younger sister Samantha together with
his divorced parents Olivia and Mason
senior Mason discovers facts of life and
finds out what it means to be human
link water took an inventive approach
with boyhood shooting the film over the
course of 12 years from 2001 to 2013
with the exact same cast the end result
is a touching depiction of personal
evolution as viewers watch Mason
literally grow up from year-to-year
boyhood leaves Netflix a little later in
the month on November 20 Pitts check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Applause]
[Music]